valerie is with us in california hi
Valerie how are you hi I'm doing great
Dave thank you for taking my call sure
taco Jonah Hill well I wanted to say
that well my husband lost his job due to
covert in March and we were working with
big L intensity on baby step two and we
just started in February so we were
working on our plan and after he lost
his job he did get a second job sorry he
got a job he found a job but it was
making a half of what he was making
before so in order to compensate
I used Ken Coleman's template for a
resume and I got hired for a second job
so now I'm still working full time
that's a problem with using those can
common things I work yeah it did work
thank you Ken good and so I guess my
question is today my question is I feel
a little bit guilty that I took on a
second job because there's going to be
so many people that don't have work and
but what this ghazal intensity I really
feel like we need to do it so what you
get out of debt so let me free you of
the guilt you are an amazing woman I
mean you're stepping up big-time
I I would not have any guilt about the
fact that you've pulled in a second job
while many are out of work that is not
your situation it's not your
responsibility to get all those other
people employed you stepped up let's
just be honest you were affected your
husband got laid off like millions and
millions of other people and he stepped
into something else kudos to him he's
making half of what he did make and you
had an opportunity to step in and make
up the difference please don't feel any
guilt you should be proud of yourself
you're not taking this jobs not gonna
solve anybody's problems that's not a
that's a false premise yeah you know and
you got a sweetheart and you have a
sweetheart
occasionally when I have one which it
happens just very occasionally but and
I'm thinking something like this and I'm
thinking you know it's my job to fix
somebody else's thing that is
their job to fix kind of thing my wife
will just look at me and say hey Jesus
what's up Oh in other words in other
words you're not the Messiah
hillbilly yeah and so it's his job to be
God not your job you can't fix
everything
it's not even though your heart says I
love people and people are hurting and I
want to help people but you can't fix
everything and so that that's you know
you're not harming anyone else believe
me someone else wants a job in freakin
California they will find a job or
they'll go to another state and find a
job you're not destroying someone else's
life you're not being greedy you're
simply a kind person with a big heart
who doesn't afraid artwork get them get
them get it get after it